if you're happy you're successful nobody
can nobody can step into your life and
and when you're happy about who you are
and what you do
because and tell you that you're not
successful because you're not happy
doing the stuff that they feel like they
would be happy doing that doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense yeah that's the
dumbest thing on earth i get so
frustrated when you see someone who is
happy right and then someone comes in
and kind of brings the gloomy cloud in
like but when are you gonna get married
or but one in five four three two
one hello everybody welcome to genius
friends
hello everybody hi everybody hi
everybody it's me maangchi
today we are going to use a little bit
of sugar
sugar sesame oil sesame oil sugar this
is very delicious
if you guys don't know who that is um
one of the first og korean chef people
on youtube was this lady named maangchi
and maangchi means hammer in korean
which is so funny because there's also
david the name of david chang and stevie
wiebe's band but
she was one of those first people out
there that made korean recipes there
weren't a lot of people on youtube in
the beginning that were making korean
recipes online yeah and maangchi was one
of the first ones she was funny she's
still around she's still around she's
still doing [ __ ] but she's very
successful um she just kind of reminds
me of all those ajamas you see at church
yeah you know she's very delicious
yeah this one right here she's so cute i
think why she's so fame popular among
the fans is that she seems very
authentic nothing is fake
yeah she's just doing what she does
and so she always cooks like these like
when i look at the recipes they don't
i've made several recipes they're not
like in my personal opinion
the greatest but it's a great foundation
for you to kind of make it adjust it to
your taste yeah right so she kind of
goes over all the stuff that you
basically would do to create this
typical korean dish and then you could
always make adjustments for yourself yep
one of the weird things that i've always
ran into is like
i think now when we talk about food
people always like to bring up this
thing called like authenticity right
which i which i understand right there's
a difference between
making food your own and then also
misrepresenting food right because the
misrepresentation of food is what people
dislike a lot so for example like i
talked about this kid the spring roll oh
yeah oh
years ago i made this joke right about
this guy who you know he was teaching
people how to make spring rolls and it
was it wasn't him per se because he was
like an employee of this publication
and it just was terrible they're like
well he's just making it his own way i
was like ah that's not what they said
though they said this is how you make
spring rolls i thought it was a joke
yeah everybody thought it was a parody
so there's a difference between like
making it yourself and then
misrepresenting an entire culture and
then kind of profiting off of it right
which yeah i get it it's not really in a
to me it's annoying right because i
don't want people to think that this
[ __ ] thing is a part of my culture and
what i grew up with because when we have
these conversations and you miss spread
this information they go oh yeah i know
how to eat that stuff or i know how to
do this and you see it and it's not the
food it's like that's not even a
interpretation of the food you just made
something completely different and now
you're spreading this thing about my
culture improperly to other people and
that's the part that i get annoyed with
misrepresentation versus like doing your
own thing or two different things you
know what is doing your own thing is it
putting different ingredients
yeah different ingredients are just
making like it's like it's like for
example oh be careful yeah it's like for
example let's say uh i come into this
country right i'm in like i don't know
anything about it i really don't know
anything about american food at all
right whatever that may be
um
i take a piece of bread and i put a hot
dog in it right and i go hamburger
people be like no no no that's not a
hamburger you don't know it is a
hamburger mm-hmm
i was like no that's a hot dog so no
it's not a hot it's meat and it's bread
it's my interpretation of what a
hamburger is and people be like what the
[ __ ] are you you're insane that's not a
[ __ ] hamburger and that's essentially
the same thing but that rule never
applies towards like for some reason
like asian food they just go oh it's my
interpretation it's like if i did the
same thing to you
if i took pasta
and i put a bunch of cheese in it and i
go spaghetti
right that's not an american food but a
lot of american people make that in
their homes yeah yeah no that's mac and
cheese i got no no no it's noodle and
sauce it's spaghetti it's my version of
spaghetti people people would flip their
[ __ ] lid especially italian people
what do you mean a spaghetti a spaghetti
is a type of noodle
that's a macaroni you watched way too
many of those like feedback from italian
malls
vincenzo's plate i love his channel the
most is that that well no this is this
guy he's an italian chef and he reviews
other people making italian food and
then he also does his version of it and
he's really cool because he actually
likes it when people interpret like
italian food their own way yeah you know
and he goes oh it looks like it tastes
good it's not probably traditionally
what it is but it still looks like it's
good and i think that's a lot of
people's attitude but they're not
misrepresenting their food though right
what about like if you go to korea
there's there
italian food is super popular
but then there's like for example a
pizza that has sweet potato crust inside
yeah that's an interpretation of the
food they're not saying that this is how
pizza should be or this is what pizza is
right this is korean style pizza this is
how we like it which i prefer
i personally like korean stuff italian
absolutely i don't know what it is it
just it's more on like the korean
palette i love it yeah and i think a lot
of people when they hear this they might
say like what's the big deal it's it's
not that they're doing anything
wrong personally but when a million
people see something and it represents
who you are it is it's a little annoying
is it kind of like when someone say oh
you're korean you must eat dog yes it's
like some [ __ ] like that but not to that
extreme that's kind of hyperbolic in our
case but
it's just i just like it to be
represented properly first and then take
it however you like because then people
will know at least like oh this isn't
how it's traditionally done or not even
traditionally like this is a completely
different dish but i like this version
better then that's fine too i don't
really care but when you when you kind
of
want to be at the forefront of somebody
else's culture when you're not a part of
it and you misrepresent it and then
you're fine with it then it's like why
do people even like to do that because
nowadays it's like it's more about
creating content it's not about whether
what you put out is right correct what
it does if what the purpose of it it's
just more like i need to put out content
immediately now now now now and then for
people to like if people like it then
i'm worth something that i could build a
business off of it they don't care about
the aftermath of what happens after like
i see it too many times with food
specifically it happens all the time
wow that's this is the age that we're in
now i understand that when you have to
create content you need to you know
create buzz and you need to be
consistent with it but a little effort
to do something right would be nice
isn't it crazy that
i feel like the main focus to
kind of see yourself successful is going
into this creating content now being
part of this
crazy eternal like this trend that has
such a high turnover yeah like people's
definition of what success is now is
really
it's annoying to me you know because
sometimes when i i meet people from back
home right they go oh you made it and
i'm like what does that mean
what does you made it
why do you look at what i do and say
i've made it when i look at your career
and i'm like you've made it because
for some reason people idolize people in
entertainment as if
the people in this space are worth more
than what everybody else does in this
world and it's it's a job
what we do is a job it's no different
from what you do like that's the odd
thing to me i have people who are in
professional careers and they go man
dude like what you're doing is so dope i
was like what about what you do you're a
[ __ ] doctor dude
like are you [ __ ] insane yeah like
why would you ever look at what i do and
and undermine what you do just because
more people see what i do what people
see that i do doesn't mean that there's
value to it it's just that my job
pertains that there are eyes on me
that's it it's just it's just this
outward validation that is the key
motivation for everybody now
isn't that weird that
our go-to places this social media app
and to certain people it's just a hobby
it's just a place to you know connect
with friends but then majority of us to
really like this the new tv it's the new
media for entertainment like i said i
don't have a problem with social media
i've made my whole career off of it i've
i've been allowed to connect with people
with it i think that the moment that
people stop realizing that this is just
a tool for fun
but it yeah that's the thing that's
where that that's a blurry line is that
people find that
these numbers that we love to look at
they see that as an equivalent to
your popularity or like your success
and
i don't know it's you think anybody's
going to give a [ __ ] about you after you
die because you got 10 million views on
a tick tock dance that everybody else
did nobody gives a [ __ ]
literally nobody gives a [ __ ] a couple
of people might come up to you and be
like hey dude i saw your tick tock dance
and you could take that in and
appreciate it right but you keep you
keep going for the next one and the next
one and the next one
and then what
absolutely nothing yeah if you want to
make a career out of it that's perfectly
fine but you've also seen this too and i
know a lot of young people understand
what i'm talking about why is it that a
lot of people that you follow disappear
after three or four years
two three years i've been on the space
12 years and i make more money now than
i did when i first started
right so
the odd idea behind this is that they
think oh i'm just having fun you are
having fun but now it's up to you to
kind of navigate through this whole
social media and popularity thing and
understand that if you don't create
something that's going to last this is
only a blip in your life and if you
value yourself based on what other
people say when that goes away you lose
value yeah they start to go crazy i see
it in my peers all the [ __ ] time and
i look at them and they're the most
desperate human beings ever and it's
hard it's hard to especially when i tell
them to their face right
it's almost like
this media or this platform
you know people want
power right people want the control they
always talk about that it's like there
is a huge power that you could totally
control but
it's just the question of can you are
you able to handle this power that's
it can take over yeah i think like the
hardest conversations that i've had
especially with peers in this space is
when they
they're scratching so hard for relevancy
right to be relevant
but the sad thing when i see that is
that okay so years ago you used to get
three hundred thousand four hundred
thousand maybe even a million views on
your on your videos right
felt great you were making a lot of
money people recognized you a lot more
uh after time
people move on to other creators the
platform changes a little bit you chose
to do the same thing over and over
and then you expected a different result
it doesn't make sense right things
evolve and change television shows
season by season new writing new
episodes well you haven't written a new
episode in ages and you expected people
to continue to watch your reruns as if
it still feels fresh
and that's what a lot of these content
creators did
so you know they look down on stuff like
tik tok or whatever i can't do tik tok
because i was banned so cause you cursed
him yeah so i got banned from tick tock
and i i have to appeal to get to you
know create more content again but i
don't really like tik tok right it's not
really for me
i prefer instagram and i i actually like
podcasting so i i've transformed and i
moved on to different spaces
the most offensive thing that these
older creators do
when they when they say stuff like that
is that you kind of spit on the faces of
the 30 000 or 40 000 people that still
watch you now those people matter more
than everybody else who was here and
disappeared no matter what content you
put out they're there ready to support
you with their time
and their dollars so when you focus on
this new crowd which is great too to
grow your audience but you should never
forget about these people who stuck
around and are still supporting you and
they still wait for your guidance and
they still wait for your content every
day those are the ones that you should
really care and love about those people
that take their time to come to your
shows those people that come up and say
hi to you to tell you about how you
change their life you're and you're
still scratching for this relevancy from
other people who will see your content
once and disappear the next day and it's
not right because when you see that on
tick tock they're on tick tock you'll
see everybody's tick tocks ten thousand
views five hundred thousand thirty
thousand one million twenty thousand ten
thousand five thousand four thousand
three million because none of these
people actually are there to stick
around
a lot of content people now
these companies are getting smart they
look at their metrics and they go oh
i'll pay you like a thousand dollars for
these videos they're like oh but i get
20 million views on tick tocks that's
cool nobody buys your [ __ ]
your conversion rate's terrible because
you're not developing a relationship
with the people that [ __ ] with you and
so this is the this is the issue that a
lot of companies are having with a lot
of these influencers they're they're
quick content people and they don't
develop their audience i've had this
podcast now each podcast what i don't
know like on the audio site it's 30 40
000 listings this one gets like 20 or 30
000 40 000 depending on who comes on or
what the topics are yeah
those people who who come in i
appreciate every single one of them
because they've been around for a long
time and they come in to listen to this
hour and a half podcast um
and those are the people that i want to
focus on right because when you when you
do that and you say that oh i'm i i want
more views well you kind of you're
saying [ __ ] you to these other people
what about the people who support you
you know so
when
so
you are definitely one of those
survivors who are
you know
um adjusting to the trend right like
because
you are currently in this podcast
platform which has become a part of a
trend i mean to be honest i think i kind
of got lucky with the podcast thing
because when i started the pot it wasn't
a trend yet yeah yeah i got i just yeah
but you were willing to
re-navigate right yeah i just did
something that i enjoyed and then it
just happened for me yeah so for you
when you are
changing things what are a couple things
what are a few things that is on your
mind to make sure that it could be
successful for example the whole
audience thing that you're having as an
example about other people who are not
thinking about their audience and
they're thinking about more of like the
one-offs well for me i don't think about
success i think about dedicating myself
to something that i enjoy
and if the aftermath is that it's
successful i'll figure out a way to make
money off of it right or if even if i
don't make money i'll make money
somewhere else so i can do something
that i enjoy
i think i'm very blessed with the fact
that the people who have followed me
they follow me so hard and they support
me with their dollars and on top of that
they come back and they watch why do you
think your fans are so
uh dedicated to you i don't know
i think like i
you know i i don't know
i but i meet these people and they kind
of
it's it's it's reciprocal right so it's
it's this relationship of
me doing what i do helps them do what
they do and because what they and them
being successful makes me want to work
harder too it's cyclical it works like
this if the people who follow me were
pieces of [ __ ] i wouldn't want to do
this
right
and i i do feel that i'm a very unique
voice in this space and i didn't realize
it until i started going into
mainstream industry right
acting auditioning or whatever and
talking face-to-face with these people
who i felt were on the same wavelength
as me but when i met them in person they
opened up their dirty [ __ ] filthy
mouths i'm like you guys are all those
people that number one you either look
down upon make fun of talk [ __ ] about
[Music]
you're them you just pretend like you're
not this podcast is brought to you by
better help listen my friends if you
haven't focused on your mental health
this year
stop waiting
you have to focus on yourself listen
better help can assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist listen you don't
have to sit in an uncomfortable waiting
room and you can message your counselor
at any time while setting up weekly
video or phone sessions and it's super
convenient and more importantly it
allows you to be in your own safe and
comfortable environment i understand not
everybody's used to like traditional uh
in person or offline therapy right
special offer for genius brand listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com genius so visit
betterhelp.com genius and get that 10
off and work on that mental health my
friends
you know what i mean
so when i with these people out here i
feel like i can they see a lot of
themselves in me and i see myself in
them right
because when somebody has like for
example the conversation of when
sometimes when i meet people they go oh
like i want to
do what you do or you know i always tell
them like don't
follow what i do i think like listen to
the stuff that i say that i'm passionate
about and the things that i care about
you have to find out what you care about
and be passionate about that
right
and that's why i feel like
maybe that's the type of advice and the
vibe that i give out is the reason why
these people stick around
right and i've met some people who have
listened to me since they were like 15
16 years old and then you have a very
long-term relationship with your
audience they've known they've watched
you for like 10 years yeah and they're
arguably way more successful than i am
which is crazy to me and that actually
makes me feel really good they go oh
yeah i was down like there was a buddy
of mine who's very very successful now
and actually he's i've worked with him
and his company that he built sponsored
my podcast a few times oh that's cool
and he told me that he found out about
me years ago before we became friends
because of these videos that i was doing
giving out life advice and it helped him
reevaluate where he puts his time and
energy into
because he was having a hard time
getting over his ex-girlfriend
and there was a video that did years ago
talking about where you
place your value in or who you place
your value in is it's it's very
important so like when you break up with
somebody and you dwell on this human
being who left you it's okay to feel
that way but the fact that your value is
based on what this person that you're
with tells you is a very bad indication
of where you're at personally where how
do you value yourself and he took that
video and it kind of like changed his
life and now he owns like this
multi-million dollar company and then he
sponsors my podcast so
wow yeah it's it's so
nuts to see how that happened that's
awesome if only
everybody could do that
yeah because like and also too when i
say success to success is such a a
relative term right um what does success
mean yeah i was gonna ask you what is
what does success i think success is
happiness
i agree if you're happy you're
successful nobody can nobody can step
into your life and
and when you're happy about who you are
and what you do
because and tell you that you're not
successful because
you're not happy doing the stuff that
they feel like they would be happy doing
that doesn't make any [ __ ] sense yeah
that's the dumbest thing on earth i get
so frustrated when you see someone who
is happy right and then someone comes in
and kind of brings the gloomy cloud in
like but when are you gonna get married
or but when are you gonna do this when
are you get like things when are you
going to suck my left nut
how about that like these like
milestones that like a lot of people
think you should have that will bring
happiness but it's like or you know
people who
got what they want but they're like oh
but i don't have this i don't have that
it's like what what makes you think that
that's gonna make you happy though
you're there's gonna be like for example
what more do you need yeah like that's
gonna bring more issues you know that
but yet people are so sometimes just so
i don't know
like
they
they
it's never enough yeah and
i like that personally like i want to be
surrounded by folks who
feel like they have more than enough
because i'm very i'm like a sponge and
probably you know that is that whatever
the vibe are you really
are you really a sponge wait what is
that from i don't know that
you don't know what i'm talking about
you being a sponge
is who is that rosemary no i'm just
gonna talk like this for the rest of the
podcast to see if you eventually talk
like me since you're a
sponge i probably will and not exactly
like that but probably something similar
um but yeah like if i'm surrounded by
negative energy then i become negative
and so i love
i if i think about it in the past like
when
when i was a little bit younger like in
college years a lot of people say that
they love being around me because i'm
such a like
a vitamin c type of girl like they bring
i bring such like positive vibe and i
love that and i want to keep doing that
but
when i'm surrounded by negative people
talking about like you know stats and
everything like you know being part of
this certain status yeah i mean that's
because that's the only way that they
can value happiness to them it's right
or when they come to me and they're like
holy cow you have x amount of followers
it's like cool
i i get very like not shocked but like
uh speechless i'm like i don't know how
to
what to say because
i didn't first of all i didn't really
earn that second of all i that doesn't
mean anything for me it's just like oh
this is cool like i get to use a
platform but
there's it doesn't define who i am
so when they come around i'm just like
putting a smile but i don't know how to
react to it because
that's not my job yeah it's just like we
had a conversation with uh with a buddy
of ours and we were talking and having
to and
he
he's like one of these really really
just kind people i think i think when i
when i look at him
he's he's a lot more sensitive than uh
most of the guys that i hang around with
are right which is actually a good thing
for me because i i like his level of
sensitivity i think he's like like my
level he no you're you're you're you get
buttered
he's poor that's you yeah he's he's just
a really really kind soul so like when
when when people say things to him it
makes him reevaluate how he feels about
his personal life if they're
somebody that's within his circle right
you know i'm very different even if
you're in my circle i'll have an open
ear and i'll listen but if you say
something negative about the way that i
live it won't
wreck me it'll just be like all right
shut the [ __ ] up like i'll do what i do
but no nobody really does that yeah i
was gonna say you don't really have that
kind of yeah because i don't have idiots
in my life you know so
you know in this friend's case
his living situation is what i consider
very ideal right but from everybody
else's perspective of what they think
that somebody of his age should do they
have an opinion about how he should live
his life which is so [ __ ] dumb like
me hearing him telling me this was
irritating me not he wasn't irritating
me but the fact that there are people in
a circle that could tell him how to live
his life yeah when number one they don't
have the right number two their
definition of what success is is very
very subjective yeah and number three
they're seeing it from a lens of what
how they think they should live so for
example
he has a really dope family very
supportive and it's it's a
multi-generational home right
you have people who like their
children's children will live in the
same home in the same area there's a big
enough area for it and you know they
people come in from an outside
perspective and they say oh
well how come you should probably move
out you know you you know live away from
your family now and have your own place
why
the man works parents are happy with him
being around they want to spend time
with their son they have a completely
separate area of the home it's a
multi-generational home
so for what purpose did this person feel
like he can come in and tell him you
should move out of your house because
what he's basically saying is that
you're a leech to your family
as an adult you shouldn't be living with
your parents anymore exactly because
you're not doing that you're not a real
man that's essentially what this person
is saying without having to say it
however
number one who the [ __ ] are you number
two you don't know his living situation
number three everybody in that household
is happy yeah so where the [ __ ] do you
go off telling this person about what he
should do that makes you think that
would make him a better adult human
being or man you do not live in his
situation yeah i look at him and i i'm
envious of it yeah not because and by
the way it's not like he's not paying
rent or giving them money too
no like he's still he's doing his part
of his job it's just that he's working
the money is going to the family he's
going into the family and on top of that
he can build a better future which is
what parents want you do not have that
type of synergistic relationship with
your family don't put your [ __ ] on
to him
it's just i i dislike that so much
because if i was him i would be like hey
bro shut the [ __ ] up i'm happy and you
live your life yeah and
it might be the cat case that this guy
just doesn't have enough information so
it's just based on
like normal
but even if it's not standard whatever
well so here's the other thing and the
reason why that's also annoying to me is
because if he doesn't know him on that
level he's not that close to him
that means he shouldn't place his such a
harsh opinion about his life if he
doesn't know him like that
so
it goes hand in hand sure because if he
did know him on a personal level he
would never say that because he would
look at what he has and be like this
isn't a pretty amazing life his parents
wants him around and when they have kids
in the future they want to be able to
take care of their kids and then help
them out with that and they'll be in the
same household they have a it's amazing
it's it's actually how families are
normally built or should be built in my
personal opinion yeah to be in a village
where everybody takes care of each other
for somebody to step in and tell them
that what you're doing is wrong
and what you should this will better
your life is very presumptuous if you
don't know this person at all especially
when this person is happy yeah his
happiness is already defined yeah and
when i look at him
happy
and i'm and i'm very happy for him
mm-hmm
because when i heard that when we saw
how they were living i was like this is
amazing i was like this is freaking
awesome and they're they can help out
financially too and it's just great it's
one of those that
it's not part of their norms so they
find it oh this is not
normal this is not the way everybody
does so why it doesn't seem right
i think that's the case because
exactly everyone's happy so why
change it you're not hurting anyone
you're you're
you're making your own there's no
there's no there's no real like moral
dilemma yeah like what what is it i
think you know because i know cause even
the phrase too like they're happy leave
them alone well they're happy leave them
alone only make sense of what they're
doing isn't harmful exactly and what
they're doing isn't harmful so
what is the problem it's nothing but
happiness and quality
relationships that they're creating and
saving a lot of money not spending on
rent yeah so why not and that's
that's what i i i like having those kind
of people in my life
let's just put it that way yeah and
that's that's what we were talking about
too when we say like the definition of
like success is happiness
if you're happy doing what you're doing
you are you are
just as successful as the person out
there with a gazillion dollars and if
they're happy if you in my personal
opinion when it comes to monetary so
having money is great because it solves
a lot of problems but it doesn't
necessarily mean that you'll be happy
correct that's the hard part for people
to understand you think that the more
money that you have that you're going to
be happier and happier guess what when
you forget about your previous woes and
you're just there by yourself with your
own thoughts and now you're in this new
status quo of your new life you're going
to have other things to complain about
it happens all the time the people that
complain the most in my life are the
people with the most money it's [ __ ]
annoying
it's annoying what do they complain
about everything about society the
government um
just all this stuff it's like you talk
so much
you complain so much when you have so
much makes no sense to me so whenever
somebody says if i have money i'll be
happy no you'll be less stressed because
you don't have to worry about the bills
that you have to pay next the next day
but it doesn't necessarily mean you'll
be happy because if you're a miserable
person no matter how much money you have
in the bank you will always be miserable
you will always drag down the people who
are around you because that is the state
that you choose to be in the money
doesn't change that it makes your life
easier but it doesn't make you a happier
person
show me otherwise i have yet to see it
and i'm already you know i'm around a
lot of rich people so it's like
i i've yet to see that
where is it
why is it that the the people that i
know that i that are very close to me
financially they do decent they don't
have as much money as a lot of my other
peers but they talk about joy the things
that they want to do the future being
appreciative what they have more than
these people who have monetarily three
times as much three or four times but as
much as them
it's it's ridiculous i wonder what is
the range where people will be
not too like you're not too rich so that
like where
how you could control that money and
happiness i think if you can pay your
bills you have food in your stomach
and you could save up for your kid's
future you're you're pretty financially
good and even then a majority of the
stuff that you have to give your kids
isn't money is the tools to make them
survive and be successful
we've seen that time and time again yeah
some of the most successful people we
have that have great high paying jobs
weren't they didn't come from a lot of
money they came from parents who had
good values and great work ethics
right
and either way like we have kids our
kids are going to be way better off than
i was when i was a kid who's going to
teach him how to build things so neither
of us could do it what are you talking
about i'll pay for that
see
i said
uh i can't build things so it's like i
can't either you know so when we have
this thing of there's youtube they'll be
fine that's true
you know like i'm we we want to give
these kids tools right teaching them how
to navigate this world
um we don't see that a lot with with
well i don't know our friends i think
our friends are really great but you
know when you see that [ __ ] kid who
doesn't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
they kind of you know we talked about
this earlier today where i think a lot
of the biggest problems that asian
parents have is that they only teach
them one thing it's a singular thing of
obey what i say and then you will be
successful yeah that is the life lesson
that they give is that authority is
important i am your authority if you do
as i say you'll be successful
well how do i get to that it doesn't
matter you just listen and do what i say
well you're creating these [ __ ] asian
american kids who are [ __ ] useless
and if and if these words hurt your
feelings that's probably you
you were probably that kid that still
till this day whenever whatever move you
[ __ ] make the first thing you think
of isn't is this good for me you go will
my parents beat my ass
before we continue this podcast my
lovely brain farts we are brought to you
by purple and i can't tell you how much
i love my purple mattress because it has
been giving me some of the best sleeps
of my life start loving yourself by
respecting your rest with the purple
mattress before my purple mattress i was
sleeping on a quilted bag of
butt booty pain is that you waking up
wondering why your spine hates you huh
that's you i will shame on you what the
heck of it oh bless yourself with a
purple mattress purple's technology in
their products keeps me cool supports my
back sides hips necks and shoulders just
like your girlfriend or boyfriend should
but they don't so you should get a
purple mattress it's waiting for you
baby get a great night's sleep
and it starts with having a great
mattress get a purple mattress go to
purple.com brain10 and use promo code
brain10 that's purple.com
brain10 promo code brain10 for 10 off
any order of 200 or more purple.com
brain10 promo code brain10 terms apply
yeah
if that's the mentality that you have
it's great i i appreciate that you're
respectful and you you care about your
parents opinions but at a certain point
in your life your parents are going to
die and you are not left with the
choices that you have made what do you
do then
think about it what do you do
mommy and daddy are gone
who's gonna tell you what to do what
your next steps are yeah i know it's you
know what it's not gonna be when they're
gone i'll be no it does not work like
that that is a habit you have to build
now you can be respectful and still make
choices for yourself and i've seen that
so much whenever they make a major move
they go will mommy and daddy approve
mommy and daddy are old now you're also
old
it's
boundaries people you need to learn how
to set boundaries yeah i think if you do
have the opportunity now
do it before it's too late because
i feel for them because
they
if you don't know any better and if you
know that respecting your parents is a
good thing and that's the household that
you lived in
and you don't have any other references
then that is what it is and it's not
their fault
but
for your own sake if there is
uh a time for you like right now
to adjust that to even think about it it
might be a good time to really
eventually take responsibility for the
things that you do it's hard there is a
korean drama that was really famous um
back in 2018 i believe it's called
oh shoot what was it called
case yeah
yeah it's a korean drama where basically
you see elite parents
doing whatever they can for their kids
to get into number one school
and you see the parents
doing exactly what you're saying is like
telling them what to do do this and
you'll be successful
well it turns out one of the dads
did that and basically his kid uh
became useless and he was able to see
that he is
the result of the kid's
uh condition was because of him
and he turns around to his mom
and say
this is what you taught me this is what
you told me to do i'm this old and yet i
have no idea how to control or do things
on my own all because of you
and
at first i was like this is very weird
moment but at the same time the mo i
couldn't stop thinking about it i was
like holy cow that's gonna be us in the
future
talking to our parents if we don't put
our foot down and really think about
what we want to do rather than what we
think our parents want us to do
because their our parents happiness
doesn't really mean that we're gonna be
happy in the future yeah i also too like
you know to take it off the shoulders of
the kid
you know these asian parents too they
need to have a certain sense of
responsibility as well
you have consistently tried to call your
kids stupid useless
they don't know what to do when you do
everything for them whose fault is that
that's yours you have to take
responsibility you have to take
responsibility the fact that you
disabled your child
right by not giving them the tools
in order to be successful but instead
giving them rules and telling them that
they will be successful because they
follow rules those are two [ __ ]
different things and you make your kids
into these useless human beings in
society that are now entitled they think
that they're entitled to success money
and wealth because they listen to mommy
and daddy
so there's two people at fault here it's
the kid for not standing up eventually
sacking up or pussying up or whatever
you want to call it
and then also also the parents for
[ __ ] admonishing them and punishing
them for trying to be an adult and
finding their own way
how can you do that you don't make any
sense like dislike
but isn't that sad for those who
don't have that
like we as an
american living in america we see
different point of views but if you're
at a specific community
and everyone is the same
and that is the only route to become
successful in that community like isn't
that sad that they can't get out of it
it is very sad like i said they were
bullied by their parents
and they never decide to stand up
right and
you know people can say as much you want
they go well easier said than done [ __ ]
i know i i'm also and [ __ ] i'm an
immigrant asian american imagine how
hard it was for me
like even for mario like the parents
that she sees now or not like the
parents that i grew up with i had to
fight them i had to scr you have any
doubt hardest to tell your parents that
you want to be a stand-up comic
at the age of 16 who is a pastor's kid
who's the pastor's kid
don't you don't talk to me about [ __ ]
pressure dude like i've
clawed my way to have this career it was
hard you know it was difficult a lot of
fights why do you think there's only one
of you here though
but there isn't just one of me there's
you can do it too the difference is is
that everybody not everybody let me
there's a lot of you out there that want
to have your cake and eat it too you're
too scared to make that leap because you
know for a fact that when mommy and
daddy stops giving you money you have to
live with your choices
[Music]
mom [ __ ] you cool don't have my money
then you have to be like you're right i
don't deserve your money because i need
to go make it and you have to go out
they don't want to do that they go [ __ ]
you i want to do what i want
where's my allowance
you don't get to have both ways
to your parents credit if you want to
suck their [ __ ] bank account dry then
you do exactly what the [ __ ] they tell
you to do
as an adult as an adult you're in your
mid-20s you're in your 30s you graduated
you did whatever and you're still
looking for them to give you money and
you still want to tell them [ __ ] you all
do what you want you don't have that now
because now you're their employee they
you're that's what it is they give you
money
and you're still taking it and then you
want to be like [ __ ] you do whatever i
want doesn't work like that you were an
adult now now you have to make adult
choices you cannot have your cake and
eat it too you are full of [ __ ]
you're full of [ __ ] you have to make
those hard choices i'm not telling you
that you're going to be 100 successful
but you got to figure out the things
that make you fall so you can get right
back up that is how our parents worked
right they came over to a country that
they have no idea how to like
communicate because they don't know
english but they figured it out
and they were able to provide roof under
us above us it's it's difficult it's
horrible it's hard and i think that's
what parents a lot of parents say is
that you don't know what hard means yeah
because everything's given to you which
i'm like
who gave it to them to you people
but yeah i mean they're
we did get a lot soft i think our
generation got really really soft and
sensitive yeah a hundred percent you
know um
i think everybody has that ability to
kind of okay i
when i first lost weight right there was
somebody that i used to listen to all
the time and i started listening to him
again recently because i'm trying to get
fit again and i kind of forgot what the
main factor of my motivation was for me
to lose weight aside from the health
part i understand um
i started listening to david goggins
again and the reason why i listen to
david goggins is not because i want to
be like david goggins per se
but he has this idea and mentality that
i that i really like to follow which is
doing things that make you uncomfortable
causes growth
you don't because so is that why you
started running that's why i started
running because i didn't understand
you're like but it's uncomfortable and
it's good for you i'm like what is that
what
i see where you got it but but you but
you could already see my mentality shift
now when it comes to my fitness when i
started running you're not as lazy it's
not the it's not the running aspect
that's making me lose weight it's the
fact that i'm doing something that's
good for me and it's something that i
dislike and it's a reflection of how
life is
not everything that you want out of life
is going to be easy the path to it is
always going to be hard if i keep
looking for shortcuts and ways
for me to circumvent pain in order for
growth it doesn't happen that way i
think discomfort causes a lot of growth
yeah and so
i decided to run yeah i've lost weight
before 60 70 pounds without running well
now i'm at a point now where i'm very
comfortable so how do i move past this
so i decided to incorporate running and
i started listening to david goggins and
david goggins too he never talks about
competing against others
he's always talking about competing
against the person you see in the mirror
are you better than the person you were
the day before
so
he always says too don't don't look at
what i do you don't have to be an ultra
marathon runner run 100 miles
right because that's what he does he
does ultra marathons he runs 100 mile
runs
he goes
do it based on you so for example
i'm running every other day i run about
three and a half miles right
i know
that i could probably run it all the way
through but i it's hard
i just need to get it done though
no matter how long it takes i i need to
get it done because it's good for me
mentally when you say need to get it
done is there a timeline for this then
there is no timeline
so for me as of right now it's just get
better at it every day once the habit
sets in then i can start to set goals
so that first you saw me the first three
days i was running i was in pain
it sucked i'll wake up just oh
well also you decided to run the coldest
time that's right in the most
uncomfortable situation oh my god
but it hardened my mind it hardened my
mind a lot better now good
it allows me to
look at things with a better perspective
it's the same concept of
when you go see how other people live
and it's lesser than how you live and
you still complain every day it changes
your perspective it makes you appreciate
the things that you have right and even
for me as i run now i know that when we
have kids you think i'm gonna be doing
an hour and a half run
you could
absolutely not in the first like year or
two
you know what i mean depending on how
the situation is i'm gonna i'm gonna be
tired too we're gonna be waking up you
know taking care it's gonna be
exhausting yeah so it puts things in
perspective a lot more so now that i had
this time when's the time to do it while
i have it because if i don't do it now
when the time comes when this time
disappears i'm what am i going to say
i should have done it when i have free
time yup and i just don't want to live
life like that so i go back to listen to
david goggins because he talks about
this concept of just looking in the
mirror and fighting the person that you
see
in your reflection every day am i better
than i was the day before
am i better than the person the day
before that every time you look into the
mirror and
are you supposed to say yes
if it's if it's a no then you're gonna
have to work on it i'm not beating
myself up
but it gives me motivation to continue
to continue to do work tim and i were
talking about this too where
um
the kid who cuts my hair sergio right
sergio gives amazing haircuts that's not
one of the that's
only half of the reason why i like
getting haircuts from sergio
i like sergio because i like his
perspective as a human being because a
barber too when they cut your hair
it's a very long time it's like an hour
and ten minutes when as they fade you up
you're there an hour and ten minutes
with somebody as they're cutting your
hair
every day
so
does he say something so the company
matters when i talk to him
that kid reminds
me of myself 12 years ago when i had
nothing
he has something he has a great but he's
still motivated to do things and he
talks about his future his dreams his
goals about what he wants to accomplish
and i've seen him
when i first met sergio like two three
years ago he was cutting hair for dirt
cheap giving some of the best haircuts
at a barber shop where he wasn't
appreciated
he made a leap he said you know what i
can do this on my own i'm gonna make
this leap i'm gonna open up my own
studio i'm gonna have private clientele
and i'm going to make my career doing
this
not a lot of people can do what he did
it's scary that is [ __ ] frightening
especially during the pandemic
and now he's making more than enough
money he's traveling places and he still
has other goals in mind and he's every
time i talk to he talks about what he's
achieving and what he wants to achieve
more
that's
the mentality that i enjoy and we go
back to certainly surrounding yourself
surround people even my barber it's
about surrounding myself around the
people that i want to be around
right and sergio reminds me of that so
much it's like his perspective is really
great and if if you listen to the
podcast where i had him on he's
colombian right so
his immigration story is nuts so even
for him as an individual he doesn't like
it when people complain about their life
because he knows about where he came
from and where his parents came from he
was almost kidnapped by the cartel when
he was a kid like his his
like the whole story is nuts right
his his grandmother um
[Music]
was a part of a gorilla
faction or she was kidnapped as a kid to
be a part of a guerrilla faction in
colombia she [ __ ] jumped into a river
to escape from them started up a whole
new life
yeah she started up a whole new life she
was put into a sack and dropped off from
a helicopter somewhere else in order to
survive in the [ __ ] colombian jungle
found somebody else who was like a
pastor or whatever to take care of her
she was eating scraps and foods with
dogs
in order to survive
wow
mary's a man treated her terrible or
whatever um
she yeah the story is [ __ ] nice
that's like two percent of the story
wow so he has perspective where he looks
back and goes
man i i came from greatness i came from
people who really struggle to make sure
that i have what i have and it allows
them to look forward nowadays too you
can't even say like hey
be appreciative of what you have because
what other people have you know what the
response is now i'm not allowed to feel
pain
really that's what it is it's
we now put we put more thought and
effort to the person who pities
themselves than the person who works
hard to for a better life
that's why when people say when they
listen to motivation like somebody like
david goggins he goes hey i hardened my
mind every day and i work hard towards
what i want
you want to get on this with me they go
well the first thing they ask oh well
you should care about
resting that's the first thing that
comes out of their mouth it's like it i
they're taking it to a different level
there it's like that's not what it means
yeah they take everything as a personal
attack it's like bro
well that's yeah this generation is so
soft like so sensitive i'm talking about
my generation i'm still a millennial so
like i this is our generation right now
yeah and i don't want to be a part of
that that's why when people things put
things out in the internet everybody
goes oh oh my god this person's
personally attacking me
you're sitting in your chair on a
computer
nothing is happening to you right now
nothing is happening to you
you read something that hurts your
feelings
twitter is not your job you don't have
to be on twitter you [ __ ] loser
jungle trying to survive eating scraps
with dogs like your feelings matter
you're allowed to be hurt but it's the
important thing is what does it do to
your psyche after i read comments as
people say offensive [ __ ] to me it
offends me but what happens after is i'm
not here
and then i'll go oh my god did you hear
what this person said to me
i go take a [ __ ] and i talk [ __ ] back to
you and then i block you
she gets so bad they go why do you block
me then i thought you're mentally
stronger i am
that's why i'm blocking you this is my
world [ __ ] i get to control my world
the outside world i can't control when
bad things happen i take it on the
[ __ ] chin but in this myspace i'm god
i think that's a very optimistic and
positive way of thinking yeah yeah i'm
[ __ ] it's your channel it's my
instagram it's my i'm god here dude
suck my
nuts okay i don't know if you want to go
that far yeah but uh i think it's true
though
i mean
everybody
i feel it's it's it's a lo like i'm kind
of in the middle of everything because
you know corporates these days are very
mindful about
how they represent things right because
it was based on white privilege
right but now like they're being more
concerned about considered about asian
or people of color you know and every
year now they talk about statistically
like how they've you know
uh done better to
help out others
um obviously the ratio is still like
much different but
it's all happening because of these
emotions that are being brought up and
like physically and mentally like how it
has
caused a lot of employees right
and
now you know talking about pronouns too
like at work like it is highly
encouraged to
ask somebody's pronouns before you or
just actually write it down what your
pronoun is don't let people assume it
just write it down so that we already
know
because assumption is bias right yeah
uh
so
i actually appreciate that in a sense
but in another sense i think a lot of
people are kind of like well does that
mean that we're just getting the
benefits of it right now like they're
not really treating us equally anymore
is that because oh we need more of you
guys so we're hiring you more yeah i'm
like well in one sense i was like yeah
is that the case does that mean i got a
freebie but at the same time it's like
no that means this entire if you want to
think about that way the entire time the
white people got freebies because
they're white so
and then there's all these like feelings
well conversation in the corporate world
now it's it's corporate world's very
liberal right it it's gotten to the
point now where if you
if you had said
right
during the time
um
donald trump was the president of the
united states and they knew your
political side like let's say you were
republican and you voted for trump they
won't hire you why
yeah why why why why does this person's
personal political ideologies affect his
his level of work at the company if he's
a good person does he is he is he a team
player does he bring that drama into
work those are the important things but
because now we're we're in this part of
like the feelings party
people look at oh is this person gonna
hurt my feelings these companies suck
ass so bad they're so
these companies to me in my personal
opinion are toxic because
they are trying to control things that
you cannot control
you cannot control how people feel you
cannot control how people are going to
be offended by things you could do your
best to try to minimize it but that it
just doesn't do anything people just
talk [ __ ] somewhere else
yeah yeah there's always going to be
more complaints
that's why i'm saying like what does it
end is the question
really i mean we're
genetically we're just people who
are greedy
you know just want more and more and
more they just like protect my personal
feelings how about you just come in and
do your [ __ ] job and if you bring up
issues that are outside of work you're
[ __ ] fired let's do that
do whatever the [ __ ] you want but in
this company i hire good people and you
treat everybody here with [ __ ]
respect
yeah i don't care if only life was that
simple though yeah like i don't like
enforcing things like that right so for
example like if companies want to do the
pronoun thing that's perfectly fine
let's say if i had a huge mega company i
would say this you don't have to label
your pronouns but if somebody asks you
to call them a certain pronoun just do
it
yeah right instead of like making a
comment for example like i there was
someone who was talking about this is
that people look it's he's a male and
they look at him and they say
he but that person
wants to be called as they
the response should be okay that's the
case great
instead they go back and say oh but you
look like you would be a straight man
just why would you say that it's like
like i understand like the the polit the
like
the consequences i guess a lot of people
talk about misgendering or whatever
i just don't care i'm just like if
somebody comes up they're like hey i
don't like be calling you he just called
me a day i was like listen
i'ma call you a day but if i [ __ ] up
here in there don't get mad at me
because it's not something that i'm used
to or anybody is right now just give me
the grace where i'll [ __ ] up
yeah that that's fine
if you genuinely make a mistake also i
think it's one of those things like if
you're coming to this world
a corporate where
they are trying to put
uh a balance you know to be as equal as
possible as an employee respect that
don't come back and say oh but you look
like you'll be a straight guy that's why
i want to call you a he
i don't care i'm just like hey call me
that it's like all right i'll call you
with that just just give me some time to
get used to it like i i'm a [ __ ] up you
know what i mean that's fine i barely
remember people's names you know yeah
that's the hard part you know so it's
like i gotta remember your name your
pronoun and all this other [ __ ] too and
then what your favorite [ __ ] color is
like [ __ ] let me do my jaw yeah give me
some time like it takes a it takes a
minute you know yeah it just nobody
wants to give i mean i'm adjusting to it
i'm just like people just don't want to
give people grace that's all like they
don't they don't they don't
they don't like fallacy or flaws in
human beings at all they just think that
oh
because i told you this is how it's
going to be it's like dude how many
times have you told me to put the
[ __ ] toilet seat down and i still
[ __ ] up till this day but it's just
better than it was the day before you
know
that's all that it is
i'm glad you admit that
of course i can't do it all the time
it's not going to happen you'll never
get to that point it's just going to get
better unless the kid gets dunked into
the toilet it's just going to make me
laugh and then i'll start doing tick
tocks
bam look at my kid and i'll be like your
daddy's gonna shower you from moving
forward that's fine she's like all right
time to shower just throw them in the
water
yep
throw some powdered shampoo on it add
riley in there yep all in one and just
swish them all like a big soup
well guys
that was fast and i felt really fast
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast hope you guys enjoyed that
conversation we talked a lot about
parents bullying asian kids and asians
not taking uh personal responsibility
for their actions
if you guys have experienced this if you
agree with this if you disagree talk
about in the comments and
uh we'll see you guys next time every
thursday and sundays you can catch
meriel at merriel underscore underscore
song that's geniusbrainpodcast
and we'll see you all next time
peace